c'était l'un des chocs du week-end en
fédéral 2 Versailles installé dans le
top 6 recevait le quatrième heureux sur
sa pelouse synthétique après une
première période équilibrée se sont
finalement les joueurs locaux qui sont
devant à la pause le score très à 8 pour
les bleus et blancs les intentions de je
n'étais pas là on voulait mettre
beaucoup de rythme on a voulu mettre
beaucoup de volume de jeux donc du coup
il y a eu quelques mois d'adresse voilà
donc beaucoup de fautes de main qui nous
ont à chaque fois remis dans notre camp
donc c'est ça qui a créé un petit peu ce
déséquilibre en en première mi-temps et
qui a à chaque fois remis l'euro dans
l'avancée au retour des vestiaires
Versailles rectifie ses erreurs de la
première période et prend le large après
avoir inscrit plusieurs essais le
clavier Vinois valide sa douzième
victoire de la saison score final 38 à
17 on avait à cœur de faire un un gros
match le dernier à domicile sur les la
phase régulière donc voilà il nous
fallait gagner il nous fallait gagner
aussi avec le point de bonus pour
pouvoir prétendre à la qualification
donc c'était à un moment important
c'était un match quasiment de phase
finale pour nous donc l'objectif rempli
les garçons ont mis beaucoup de coeur on
a fait vraiment un gros match après
cette victoire les objectifs des
versaillers sont remplis l'équipe et 6e
de la poule les joueurs de la cité
royale ont assuré leur qualifications
pour les barrages à la base on était sur
un maintien et au fur et à mesure on
s'est dit qu'on allait chercher un peu
plus loin et là sur les deux trois
derniers mois on a dit pourquoi pas
le top 6 pour pouvoir aller au moins
chercher les phases finales et en tout
cas voilà c'est ce qu'on a fait prochain
match pour Versailles le dimanche 16
avril sur le terrain du Havre le leader
du championnat l'occasion pour les
joueurs de la cité royale d'accrocher un
nouvel adversaire prestigieux à leur
tableau de chasse